today is april 8
i am karen aronson
we are talking with barry zessager a
member of the mit corporation and its
executive committee
barry served on the search committees
that nominated its current president
susan hockfield
and mit's current chairman dana mead and
is a member of the committee looking for
the next chairman
she is also one half of the couple whose
name graces the hugely popular zessager
sports and fitness center at mit
or the z center as it's widely known
barry thank you for talking to us it's
my pleasure
let's start with the z center
what is it like to have your name on one
of the most popular buildings on campus
oh well it's just delicious
it's wonderful
it was a great thing for us to do and
now we get so much back from mit because
whether it's a
faculty or staff that i might meet
because i'm when i'm here on corporation
or executive committee work or just
students when they see my name tag
saying are you the
uh of the zesger center we just get a
lot of feedback
and this was always
al's vision was not only to give back
but give back during your lifetime so
you can see the benefit
so we've gotten it in spades
before it opened did you and l have any
idea of how popular it was going to be
no you know we weren't thinking about
that
first of all i wasn't thinking about it
very much because i hardly knew mit but
al who is the graduate here
what he really felt was that people just
couldn't be going shouldn't be going
into the basement uh into what i heard
is this dark dank pool that mit has been
using for many years believe it or not
i've never seen the
that prior pool which i guess still
exists but uh he just thought it was
terrible and and uh that mit deserved
better so uh we weren't we were thinking
more along those lines instead of
being appreciated
i don't think you can give money to be
appreciated it just doesn't work
at a place like mit lots of people want
to give money for things like cancer
research and engineering labs sure how
did you and al come to be associated
with a sports and fitness center how did
that come about oh well you know in that
sense al is
a quintessential miter because he's his
own thinker he doesn't do things because
everyone else is doing them uh and what
he he is a
not so much a believer in fit uh
swimming he's more of a believer in
fitness
and he felt that he's lived a very full
and and busy life he's still working
full-time at age 81. and
he can't do it without getting regular
exercise and so
for him that was
it was really something that he did
naturally when he was young by the time
he was 30 he realized that he had to
think about it more that he was he had a
day job he had to sit in a desk and
therefore he had to make more of an
effort to go out and get his exercise
and so that's was the genesis really in
his mind for the idea that you really
need to work out and that was as
important to him as
as that enabled him to do what he wanted
to do in life so it became very
important and he understood that
you're not going to get you're not going
to be backing a nobel laureate or
whatever but he didn't care he's he's
his own man he does what he thinks is
important and
no bills who swim in the pool well there
might be and that's just fine with us
well what we liked was the idea that a
nobel laureate might be swimming next to
a a student might be swimming next to a
staff person it's another way of
interacting breaking down all the
barriers are you a fitness buff too i am
indeed i am indeed so we
we we share that mutually
when you and he started talking about
helping mit pay for all of this
did you have strong feelings about how
it should be shaped and were you really
involved in
figuring out what it should look like
when it went up
uh
on the whole i i think i'm going to say
no
and the reason i'm saying that is that
we had very strong feelings about the
idea of it
and we had very strong feelings that we
wanted it to go faster because it did
take a while but in fairness there was a
lot going on at mit and they needed to
make sure that they could afford it uh
whatever but uh
we played a role in the idea of the pool
that it would be olympic standard that
there might be a smaller warm water pool
next to it or somewhere near to it
particularly for very young children or
older older folk
we had the idea that it'd be fun to have
the fitness draped around it so that the
two inner play together and and one can
watch the other so to speak
when it came though to design whatever
we felt that that was not our
prerogative now i know that that this is
a
a changing thing i believe in
philanthropy uh in america that is uh
that as donors get more
give larger dollars they do get more
involved and they do get very involved
and maybe i have my corporation hat on
here but i think that
there's a line that one should not cross
as a donor and so it originally was up
to mit to figure out what it could
handle what it could do
financially how it how it inter uh acted
with other buildings
and uh so i'm afraid we were more donors
than not but but some of the ground
rules we set out so i take it you're
satisfied with the way it's worked out
oh marvelously marvelously
yes it was very good